great so um welcome and thanks for joining today um really appreciate you um joining our webinar
for burp suite for devsecops um so we've got a really good lineup today um featuring our products
and a couple of insights that you told us about my name is daniel i'm from the growth team at
portswigger so we work to ensure that customers are getting value from our products and also helping
them remove any security related frictions within their organization with me today we've got ben
from our devsecops research team alex who's a product a technical product specialist here at
portswigger and then mark whittaker who's a senior web developer um so some of our attendees today
will already already be familiar with um burp suite um they may already be using enterprise edition or
they may be might be new to burp suite um but they all have a common goal in improving and working
towards um introducing security solutions so in just in terms of what we'll actually be covering today
ben will be offering his perspective and the challenges he's faced in previous roles within
devsecops um alex will be offering some insights into burp suite enterprise edition and providing
a brief overview and demo and then we have mark who will be offering um his perspective a developer
perspective on security and also demonstrating dustly our new product um making security easier for
developers um just a note um we will be in putting poll questions out throughout the webinar
and we'd be grateful if you could um answer those as and when and we do also have a team working in the
background um to answer your questions so there is a q a facility and that's separate to the chat box
um so do pop them in uh if we don't get around to your question today um we will follow up after the
session so um yep then do you mind just introducing yourself and um yeah going into the your background
thanks dan and hi everyone my name is ben smith i uh joined portswigger as a researcher in august 2021
um previously to that i uh i worked as head of devsecops for a global a global bank over the course of
my career which has spent about 20 years i've been involved in both development teams and security
teams i feel i've got perspective on both sides of that equation um i've mainly worked with uh web
scale internet and mobile banking products in high security environments and um one of the things i
want to share with you today is what i think are the key important things to get right in a successful
devsecops program so for me there's three key areas we need to think about when kicking off a
devsecops program the first one is we need to make sure we empower our developers so developers are key
for us to be able to fix problems and bugs early in the life cycle of applications
applications by being able to fix things early we reduce the amount of resource wastage but also
importantly we allow security teams to be free um to spend more time on high value activities
and the last thing i think that's really really important is that we provide developers with tangible
actionable results so what does a tangible actionable result mean it means that your security tooling
provides all the context and resources a developer needs directly into their workflow so that they
can fix the security finding and source i look forward to sharing you the area over the course of this
presentation uh the ways in which portswogger can help you meet some of these challenges but before we
continue i'd uh i'd like to share with you the results of the survey and what you've been telling us about
your devsecops programs so over 100 of you kindly responded to our survey uh it's clear from the
response that devsecops is gaining momentum in the appsec space and that most organizations are looking
to do something in terms of devsecops programs in 2023 and this has been borne out by the fact that
we had over 700 people register for this webinar we asked you where most of you are up to in your devsecops
journey it's clear from the results of the survey that most organizations are in the early phase of
adoption but over 40 of you are actively looking to deploy solutions reinforcing our view that devsecops
is a priority for organizations in 2023
next we asked respondents what they expected to do in the next six months
appsec automatic sorry access appsec automation was the biggest area focus by far and my colleague
alex were presenting burps we tend to price edition one of our products that is
the last question we asked was uh we asked our respondents was what the top three blockers
um into progress were the key themes that came out of the survey were lack of time and resource supporting
processes and systems education and buying time and resource processing systems and buying common
problems with lots of uh initiatives but the one that kind of stood out for me was the education one
especially with the kind of the key quote coming back of little knowledge of how cicd processes work
i believe that this indicates that app second dev teams need more time to understand and more education
to understand each other's technologies processes and concerns i think that creating a devsecops culture
within an organization is key is it's key for these teams to understand each other's perspectives
and then we're going to be able to understand each other's perspectives and to understand each other's
different and to understand each other's different and to understand each other's different
and to understand each other's different and to understand each other's different and to understand
each other's different and to understand each other's different and to understand each other's
different and to understand each other's different and to understand each other's different
and to understand each other's different and to understand each other's different
and to understand each other's different
create a sport ticket you've probably spoken to me in the past um ben's kind of given us the
landscape there for for where we're up to in terms of devsec ops with some insights from
from the polls that you kindly answered um we'd like to kind of continue that journey of of talking
around what product offerings um portswigger have and what we've kind of been investing in both in
terms of time and resource i'm going to take us very quickly through enterprise which as we know
some of you today use or have trialed in the past and then the plan is to take a look at dastardly
which mark is kind of going to run us through from the perspective of a developer
so when it comes to devsecops solutions at portswigger um we're going to try and target those um use
cases but also the teams that are going to be using them as well so the left hand side we've got the
the kind of developer side of the coin um and that's targeted with with dastardly which
is as dan alluded to is our our newer product um both entities are born from burp scanner so those
that have used burp suite professional um kind of know and love the scanning entity within that product
um very mature in terms of the scanning capabilities the issues that we look for and the reporting from
the back of that um so dastardly is essentially a containerized version of that burp scanner and
specifically we're trying to address those barriers that ben covered um so when we talk about things like
time and resources the idea with dastardly is that it's going to run very quickly within the pipelines
and require very minimal configuration in fact it's just going to look at a sort of preset seven
set of seven key security issues so there's no kind of um configuration required from a developer
perspective um when it's running we've also got the notion of education again that ben mentioned
um so that's inherently built into the product which mark is going to show you um but building on that
we've also got access to the web security academy another free resource um where we can look at these
issues in detail and also contain sandbox environments where developers can learn even more about the those
vulnerabilities should they wish to do so and then there's a notion of process and systems so we want
to kind of stay within our ides we want to stay within our pipelines we don't actually have the time
to be learning new new tool sets and platforms well dastardly runs right within the pipeline without
any sort of interaction um with external tools uh putting those images so it kind of ticks all those
boxes for us and on the other side of the fence with the security app teams um again a lot of you
know and love bits your enterprise are using it have trialed it in the past um we've got lots of
customers onboarding now and the notion here is that we're trying to automate and that scanning
across our whole portfolio be that weekly daily monthly scans we're producing reports getting
that picture over time of what our security posture is um and we're really trying to lift those kind
of limitations away um so it's licensed purely on concurrent scanning we don't put limits on things
like teams that can access the product itself urls domains etc etc so that's kind of positioning of the
of the two products there now we're just going to quickly jump into an enterprise overview now we've
alluded to the fact a couple of times lots of people on the call are probably using enterprise or i've
seen it in the past so we're going to keep this um fairly brief and just get a bit of a flavor and
where it fits into our our journey with devsecops so this is enterprise as we can see it's uh it's a
web-based um product in terms of how our teams access let's start with that notion of teams
and we can also configure that with some additional integrations which we'll cover off in a sec so you
set the level of access you want your teams or users to have we apply those to groups and then those
teams can only see their respective data or not as it may be everything within enterprise is site-based
so our sites are our target applications again no limits as to how many sites we can add
into our installation we can distribute everything into folders it's a game of this project-based
teams looking after their own applications as you mentioned we can set those permissions
so they can only see their their own data for kind of sovereignty everything is is site-based in terms
of the configuration level as well so once that's set we can just run our scalp schedules on top of that
and get those weekly monthly yearly cadences in terms of the reporting that's available
once we've got all of our sites set up naturally we want to run scans against those sites so very
simply what we're doing when we run scans is selecting from our site tree which application
we want to scan typically we're going to be wrapping some sort of scan schedule around that so we schedule
it for a particular day and time and then we repeat that on a daily weekly monthly process whatever is
kind of desired and that might be forever a set number of times or until a particular date and
again this is pulling all of our configuration data every time so it's very hands-off if we just kick off
a very quick ad hoc scan now if we choose to do so we can monitor the scan in real time again typically
the notion with customers is that this is running in the background and we're more interested in the
results side of things but we do have that timeline facility where we can observe the scan at the various
stages that we go through
if we look at a scan that has completed and run you'll notice a lot of dashboarding with an enterprise
because we're really trying to create that picture over time of our security posture what are our
current issues what have been resolved have any regressed and again want to capture all of that
information over time and from the back of that we've got the reporting facility so if we need to be
sharing these results internally with other teams other stakeholders we can generate reports either
summary or detailed we've introduced some compliance reporting so if you want to aggregate those results
into things like OWASP or PCI DSS and expect more to come in the future and the compliance reporting watch this space
and we very recently added a data export feature in the form of XML so if you're looking to aggregate data
into third party tools something you've built internally yourselves you can now do so and look again look
at those results over time everything we've kind of seen in terms of the UI is also exposed by the GraphQL API
so if your preference is not to be kind of jumping into a UI and managing things in that fashion
you prefer automation you prefer prefer scripting essentially everything in the UI is exposed by the GraphQL API
so we can start doing things like chaining queries together using the mutations so we can create sites
on mass we can initiate our scan schedules and alter those schedules extract very specific data sets
so that's quite a powerful tool that enables you to enhance the tool that you've got as well
just to kind of close off I'm just going to jump into our integrations page because once you've kind of got
some scan configurations under your belt some reports maybe you've learned a bit more about how to tweak
those configurations relative to your application all of which we have great documentation for you're
probably going to want to build out your installation from there so you've got an interesting interesting
issue tracking for example we support JIRA, GitLab and Trello so that's either automated tickets raised on our
preset thresholds that you define and all we can always create a manual ticket once we're investigating
those issues from results as well we already mentioned role-based access control for our users
but if your preference is to pass across existing groups from our IDP or AD we do support LDAP and SAML
from a SAML perspective if you've got a SKIM module and you'd like to manage those users a bit more directly
that's supported as well scrolling down obviously as part of this session we're very interested in CICD
integration so we have specific plugins for enterprise in reference to Jenkins and TeamCity
so these are giving you the ability to run scans within your pipeline and report that back centrally to
enterprise and don't worry if you don't use either of those platforms we've also got our platform
agnostic driver which is doing the exact same thing under the hood it's just more of a scripted fashion
and essentially as long as your pipeline can run java and that's going to be supported
and finally from a communication standpoint we've got integrations with slack so again from a developer
perspective it's great so you can target those particular channels and get up-to-date metrics on
what the scan is doing start fail finish etc etc so that's just a very quick whistle stop tour of
enterprise don't worry if you've never seen enterprise before and you're looking for a bit more info a bit
more of a deeper dive we do run regular swiggin hours where we specifically focus on on kind of
getting set up with enterprise the ins and outs and you can also always contact our growth team or
our tech support team if you are looking for some more detail something in depth and we'll absolutely
endeavor to assist you
so from a solution perspective we've kind of covered enterprise there we'd now like to move on to
dastardly which as we've mentioned is our is our newer containerized based scanning product
specifically purpose-built for development teams making things as easy as possible for web developers
dev teams to integrate those scans into the pipeline and the idea is that we're trying to take away that
pain that we mentioned earlier those barriers around removing bugs in cold be old code be old or new
and the notion of why wait for a pen tester to try and poke holes in your code when you can resolve that
yourself in your own pipeline again it's looking for seven what we think are important issues from
a development standpoint and all scans will take 10 minutes or less so again that notion that we're
not trying to hold up pipeline builds but it's a seamless integration and that moves us very nicely on to
mark section and as a developer he's going to take you through a quick setup and scan within dastardly
good luck mark i hope the deno gods are with you thanks alex yeah cross your fingers
um right hi everybody um my name's mark i'm a web developer um here a dot net developer in the web team
here at port swigger and the web team is responsible for our public website but also for a whole kind of
suite of applications and tools that we use internally to power and grow the business
um what that means is that unlike my colleagues who build burp suite and that family of tools
um i'm not a security specialist by trade my background is is in dot net web-based development
um so i've typically worked on teams where application security is a separate function
that happens downstream of my team um usually kind of side by side with a qa function
um so i was really interested to give dastardly ago um tried to integrate it into my continuous
integration and deployment pipeline i'm quite excited by the thought of that then being able to fail
my build um if a vulnerability is found in exactly the same way i would expect the build to fail if
uh a unit test or an integration test fails um so what i've got to show you today is a very simple
website with a deliberate um vulnerability in it and it's hosted on github and it uses a github
actions workflow to build the site run the tests deploy the site to azure and finally run a dastardly
scan on that site um so first thing i'll do um is show you the we'll go to the app code in github
this is a public repo if anyone's interested in looking at it in more detail passing a link to their
developers or forking the repo then um it's it's all of that is available um i'm just going to start by
making a simple code change because that will trigger a build and then we can see that that build
pipeline in in action so i'm just going to make a simple change here to the readme file um save that
and if i now switch to the actions tab in github we should see that that's queued up a build and there
it has so we've got a build at the top there cube that'll take a couple of minutes to run
um so in the meantime while that's busy what i'm going to do is show you the site
um demonstrate the vulnerability to you so you can all kind of get a clear idea of
what we're looking to detect and then we'll come back uh here and look at the code that had to be
written in order to um integrate dastardly into that pipeline and even if you're not a developer or a
coder i promise you we're not diving into anything uh too detailed um so here's the site um as i
mentioned it's very simple and there's a bit of explanatory text on there to say that it's
vulnerable to cross-site scripting or xss attacks so the way it works is if we type a message in the
box here and click submit then as long as the demo gods are smiling on us that message will get added
there to the bottom of the screen but it's being added as raw html so if we were to paste in some
javascript into that box and see what happens you'll see that that's our vulnerability in action
we've just added javascript to the page the browser has run it and it's triggered a print event on the
page you can easily imagine that being used to um you know steal customer login details or anything of
that kind so that's exactly the kind of thing that we're going to hope dastardly can find with its
best scanning capabilities um so let's switch back over to github our build is still running um if i
switch back to the the code view you'll see a folder here called github workflows this is where we build
our github actions um pipeline and it's actually just a single file it's pretty easy to follow easy to
read we've got three main sections in this file that are referred to in github actions as jobs
and the first job which is up at the top here that job is going to build the latest version of the code
test it and then package it up ready for uploading to azure um that's pretty straightforward the second
step here uh goes from there to there and this takes that packaged website that we just built and
uploads it to a web app on azure um just worth noting that this is publishing directly to a production
environment because we're just using a free web app on azure for this demo purpose so um it doesn't have
um different deployment environments in a real world situation this would be publishing to a beta or a
staging environment and running tests uh they're running running vestidly there before the site goes live
but again we're just keeping things pretty simple for this demo but the real kind of meat in the
sandwich the bit that we're really interested in looking at is this third job that's been added at
the bottom and this is what triggers a scan with dastardly and although that's only what kind of 17 lines
of of code in fact it's simpler than it looks the bit that uh makes dastardly happen is just those four
lines in the middle and we can see there that's grabbing the uh dastardly action from the github
marketplace so that's a reusable kind of package that makes it really easy to integrate dastardly into
your build and it's calling it and all it's providing it with is one piece of information which
is the url of the website that we want to scan okay um below that is a kind of optional section but the
the documentation for dastardly recommends adding this and it is really useful as we'll see later on
what this is doing is just taking the output from dastardly where it documents its findings
and presenting them to us in a more user readable you know user-friendly format so it's well worth
adding that as well but it's not really a core part of um of getting dastardly into the into the
pipeline so that is it literally those last few lines in the file were all that needed to change
in this project in order to integrate dastardly so there's nothing to download there's nothing to
install best of all as as uh you know my colleagues have mentioned already there's nothing to pay for
there's really no kind of barrier to entry with dastardly you can just um integrate and go
and go anyway that's enough time spent looking at code if we switch back to our pipeline screen
we can see that that that latest build is now completed and it's failed and it's interesting
looking here at the build history um we can see when i first built this project the build pipeline simply
ran the build and test step and everything was green gave us a green light towards the project was fine
likewise extended it then to deploy it to azure and that all worked fine and for many web developers
really this is about as far as their development pipeline goes and so far everything's looking good
right it's giving us green lights all the way but as soon as we've added that dastardly scan
for the pipeline that's when the build starts failing as you can see here in these last two steps
so um let's click in and look at that in a bit more detail and what this screen is showing us is the
kind of status of our latest build we've got a graphical view in the middle there of what happened
when our pipeline ran and as we just mentioned you can see the three those three sections of the of
the configuration file mapped to these three steps of the build build and test is good deployment to azure is
good but the dastardly scan is where our problems happened it's already giving us a little heads up
down below here that it found cross-site scripting vulnerability we can click on the scan with dastardly
step drill into a bit more information there and apart from some absolutely elite asciac at the top there
which we're all very proud of and we wear on our t-shirts um it does tell us down at the bottom here in
fairly brief detail that it found an error it tells us where the error code and what type it was and
also the severity which is judged to be high i think we'd agree with that um that's the kind of raw
output from dastardly but that third of that final little optional section of the configuration that i've
pointed out to you before gives us this fourth step of the build down the left here the dastardly scan
report so click on that you can see um at a glance the same kind of information presented in a bit
more of a graphically appealing way it tells us the vulnerability that we found and where it found it
but for me as a as a non-specialist web developer the real kind of uh juice comes into it when i click
raw output and start to look at this and what dastardly has given us here now is not just telling us
us there's a vulnerability on this page of the site but it's giving us a whole load of information
here about the detail of what this issue is which i as the developer may not be really familiar with
background of the issue suggested steps to remediate it um it's fantastic you get this similar kind of
information to what you would find on our web security academy um on the website but here it's
presented right in the build and i'd really like to think that um it's going to do a great job of
educating web developers and making us all kind of better more appsec aware uh developers um so that's
it that's the end of the dastardly demo i'll switch back to our deck and we're just going to pop another
poll up on screen for about 30 seconds or so um if you wouldn't mind responding to that please and
letting us know what you think and then i'm going to hand you uh hand you back to ben once you've had
a chance to do that give you a couple more seconds just to uh respond to that paul
okay well thanks for the demo oh yeah sorry thank you well thank you for the presentations uh mark and
alex so we've shown you enterprise edition and what that can do for security automation for your app tech
teams we've shown you dastardly and how easy it is to implement into a developer life cycle or software
development life cycle and how easy it is for developers to use um and now i'm going to show
you how these come together and how port swigger is planning to invest in devsecops over the next 12 months
so today the easiest way to start scanning in the development pipelines we just mentioned
is dastardly it's available today in uh in our container store it's easy to implement it's free
there aren't really any downsides so the key pushbacks you may get from development teams are
it's slowing down my uh my iteration cycles as you saw in max demo i think the scan took about one
minute and 33 seconds roughly so it is quite fast um we made sure the 10 findings we chose for dastardly
were all high confidence findings so if you're familiar with burp sweet pro then you'll know that
we have severity confidence so all of them are high confidence so very low false positivity rate
and lastly you saw when alex did the demo sorry when mark to the demo you saw that all the information
about the security vulnerability and how to fix it was presented directly into the developers workflow
okay what's coming next is quite exciting so what we're planning to do in the first half of this year
is we're going to develop a full-blown scanning container
that will provide two more features one it will allow you to leverage all the scan checks
that burp sweet programs burp sweet enterprise allow you to run and secondly it'll allow you to
report those scan results into your existing burp sweet enterprise uh system so you'll be able to have
a single pane of glass of both your operational security scans that you may be running every day
every week every month every year and also what's going on in development teams as well
align the security function to see right across the organization we're planning to make this really
simple to swap out so if you implement it dastardly then really all we're asking developers to do is
change the container name which as you saw again in mark's demo is a single line in the yaml file in
most ci cd systems so fairly easy to change out and add an api key so that you know the full-blown scan
is licensed hopefully you agree with us that bringing all of this together gives us a really strong
story in the devsecop space i'm going to hand you over to daniel now who's going to talk about how
we grow team can support you as well cool thanks thanks ben um so i hope that was a clear review
overview of the direction of travel that were taking that so um that just brings us to how we can support
you and your teams um and just to circle back to our survey results um there was two key areas and that
you told us that we can assist with um so the first is tooling um as arc and alex have demonstrated today
um kind of give a an overview of both products and you've seen a live demo of um dastardly being implemented
into a cicd pipeline so um we hope you can see the value that brings um and just kind of focusing back on
those two offerings uh if we look on the left um just in terms of kind of moving forward and what i'd recommend
in terms of taking action um from what you've seen today um we'd recommend sharing dastardly with your developers
um we do have um some example scripts within our support documentation for team city and jenkins
um and also as ben and alex and mark have mentioned um it is available um in github actions as well in
the marketplace there um so it's easy to obtain and that includes all the installations and instructions as
well um and yeah we'd really love to hear your feedback um you can email support at portsmouth.net
um with any feedback um if there's any questions queries around the tool um obviously people have
been asking them throughout this webinar as well and um we'll be we'll have a bit of time at the end of
the session as well to uh ask any others um and if we just look to the right with regards to enterprise
edition um if you did want to jump in directly at that level um and you knew you've not used the
product before you may have previously trialed um we are here to support you um so you can email us
hello at portswigger.net and to speak with on our sales teams we can either support you with a demo
offer another free trial or answer any questions you may have um if you do already use the product today
um if you've got any support issues um or want to find out more about some of the integrations that
alex touched on um please feel free to email us as well um we do also have a number of resources on
our website and also our youtube channel where there's some bite-sized videos there and alex and
the team walk you through that on those and um we do also host a monthly webinar on enterprise edition
so that's kind of understanding the features um and also kind of drilling down into scanning
the features um so um just leading to the second area um was education um and as ben has alluded to
that's kind of key um in getting that buy-in um and we want to make it really easy for you to educate
and enable your teams um to kind of understand security um enhance the security knowledge and also
make them more security conscious um so as part of this we would like to offer a free lunch and learn
a free lunch and a free lunch and a free lunch and a free lunch and a free lunch and a free lunch
and a free lunch and a free lunch and a free lunch and a free lunch and a free lunch and a free lunch
lunch and a free lunch lunch and a free lunch lunch and a free lunch lunch and a free lunch lunch
and a free lunch lunch lunch and a free lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch
lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch
lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch
lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch